My name is Harriet M. Welsch,
and I want to be a writer. I have to know everything,
and to know everything I have to see everything
only way to see everything is to be a spy.
I just found a big story I need both of you to help me.
Oh, we’re in.
You just got to know where to look.
For something this daring rules will have to be broken.
If Mr. Horatio finds out you’ve wondered off your future will be in detention.
So, you better cover for me.
Doomed, we’re all doomed!
One, two three, one, two, three
You are leading not following like young ladies are supposed to.
Girls can lead too.
If the story leads you follow.
Truly bit the biscuit on my mission.
You’ve got to start looking out for people besides yourself.
I messed everything up, maybe we can fix it.
I must say old bean your mustache looks positively dashing.
Thank you good sir, it took ever so long to grow.
This is a revolution!
I’m glad I’m not perfect, I’d be bored to death.